[Music]
only the brave with no intro so again
you know what's real so only the brave
is the true story of the Granite
Mountain hotshots who are a group of
firefighters ultimately what they do
there's a big forest fire happening to
control it they will burn the shrubbery
outside of it they'll create a dirt moat
you have the fire nothing to latch on to
and burn further thus the fire dies
without fields it's a great starring
cast it stars Josh Brolin miles teller
Jeff Bridges is in it Jennifer
Connelly's in it Taylor Kitsch is in it
lately Taylor Kitsch is doing great
continues that streak in here along with
miles teller I'm no longer surprised
when miles teller does a great job he
does a great job in here Josh Brolin
plays the leader of this group but it's
ultimately seen through miles tellers
eyes like he's the new guy who comes in
he's the rookie he's the one you latch
on to this movie did a lot right first
of all this is a true story these are
real people they're playing here fair to
say when the movie is being made about
true events and real people there's an
element of respect that goes into it
they're like we want to do everyone
jealous and if there's one thing we know
is that anybody who's anybody who's ever
been a firefighter and talked about it
on TV has always said they are a family
this movie gets that camaraderie down
you really feel like they are a family
even miles teller who's the new guy
coming in he's a bit of an outcast he's
an outsider to them but that changes
they do eventually accept him as family
and as much as they do the Brotherhood
element right they also do the element
of fire right fires a scary thing
although this movie is the Hollywood
movie it's easy to get Hollywood eyes
into fire movies or firefighting movies
where the fire gets put out you're like
well that's all this movie really
hammers it in where it's like fires
scary you don't want to be near this
thing and that's why these guys are
heroes I mean think about it they're a
group of people who come together to
work together so we can all go on with
our happy life there's the Avengers but
for real and the thing they do better
than the Avengers movies do is balance
the work with families that's a big part
of this movie is the balance of work and
family I imagine it's not easy to be
married to somebody who works a job that
requires so much of them in the end the
spouse of a firefighter has married into
the fact that that firefighter has
another spouse the job not only did they
make it work they made it a huge part of
the movie it's one of the reasons you
latch on I will say the setup to this
movie seemed to be going a bit fast
again with miles teller you're like why
are they concentrating on this jackoff
who is it and there's a fire someone
makes a judgment call then
but just so many things happen rapidly
but they really do smooth it out after
the set up for the most part the time
that's spent in this movie a lot of time
passes that's hard to do in a movie like
this guys in the end this movie was
great it was inspiring I look at my life
where I talk about entertainment on
YouTube and I'm like yeah they're the
heroes it really brings to light things
you take for granted you hear about
forest fires and you're like a forest
fire it'll get dealt with there are
people out there busting their asses
their personal lives are in strain cuz
they're doing what they do so we can all
just live happier lives the movie was a
great look in on the camaraderie and
family of a fire department but it also
didn't put him on a pedestal people
heroes family they're flawed sometimes
they're great sometimes they're dicks
but in the end everyone's just trying I
will remember this movie it's stuck with
me it'll stick with you I will say only
the brave is certainly worth watching
and certainly worth buying on blu-ray
right guys so only the brave have you
seen it what did you think about it
there's not a lot of firefighter movies
out there but what's your favorite
firefighter movie or movie about fires
bring on the pyromaniac movies whatever
it is whatever you think comment below
let me know and as always if you liked
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
[Music]